for for
[Music]
for
all right so the first one you have y
there you have it he pressing this way
it's pressing down so you have to y to
zero if you pay attention he's coming
from the West I don't yield to zero to
the back to the 6:00 or to the
east you always started
turning go and you start
tur I know maneuver is never going to be
camera cuz we don't film the back of
okay it's not going to be straight
down a hamar is always inward spiral or
an outward spiral in this case the
inward
spiral your thumb
turns
W to zero
okay let's try that so if I don't move
my hands going on like
this and that inward spiral is way more
visible
but because I
move it looks like it's just going
straight
down it looks like it's doing
this but it's not
turn I turn inside of it and
it's likewise
and it comes up doesn't come straight up
in it's line like
this and then I
go just going to do another inward
spiral but because I
turn it looks more straight than it is
this
[Music]
drill
turn if you pay
attention I go straight up his elbow
doesn't do
anything I turn it
see one way turn other
[Music]
a
try and the other
hand never
goes up over your
[Music]
head as you saw on this hand that's
enough you went
over the other hand is the base home
and once he holds
it it goes inward two
okay
inward inward
I want to
do
this okay just the hand work
okay you're going to know notice her
technique you're going to feel it
train cuz I'm going to ask you what
feels
different okay
you know already what is it
one everything's moving my whole body in
One Direction okay on the throw yeah
there's
no with your thigh okay say what is say
there's no with your thigh
okay all right so we have to do the x
pattern on the body okay so I don't I'm
not going to go here and then I try to
accelerate him from here that's
not come back
around because his base is not
deconstructed he'll just run out of
it okay so what I'm actually
doing is setting
up this right here this kosing in his
kosing okay and kosing is about here to
here anywhere in there I'm sweet That's
The Sweet Spot push is not not just this
part we go
again and this is what I'm setting up
this
part oh I time
it so this
drill hit
it take it easy on the
arms that's why you see
him kind of float for a second my cush
is in the way
[Music]
he goes all the way up my pushy all the
better you have to look for that just
like on E it's right
here okay so on this
technique you're
doing you're doing k
right
here but on the other
side other hand I on me there it is it's
right
hand and then you're doing the
Y right
here but you're not holding the
arm you go right
there okay try
so now if you pay
attention what's making him fall as he
comes around
right okay it's the same x pattern for
the front inward
position so that means his head has to
go this
way that will generate his leg to go
that way with a centrifical energy which
is also initiated by my spiral and
footwork and then this leg
I will project out
okay so the Hound are what are doing
that okay the
hands are making him do this with his
head so don't rip your hands out of his
grip as you're trying to accelerate them
you need to you want to stay in there
okay and as you watch me go my hands
aren't moving all that fast and
they're analyzing always for the I
adhesion inside his palms so that I keep
him loaded on the hip and I just keep it
teetering as we're going along it
doesn't stop so it's constant motion and
there's no ripping my hands out okay so
one
I see my hands are moving relatively
slow it's the hip that's doing
it don't make the
mistake of seeing it as an acceleration
go okay try it again don't rip your your
hands out of their grip match the yog
value so you have adhesion at the
Palm all
right some mistakes stepping
out and then going
forward
no but
similarly this is still going out to
then go forward I didn't step but for
all intents and purposes my hips
actually did ten con okay so if you
watch my hips they've squared there's
your ten
con my hips have squared I just didn't
put the foot back but my hips have done
it and I don't want to do
that so this
hip can't go
pass his
quad he has to stay
here oh it's going right into
[Music]
it it's not going to be there it's
different okay side again you understand
some of you will pull out one cl some of
you pull out both okay so that you
you'll understand this this one I'm just
going to go right into it here okay just
a little drill
okay TR another drill to understand it
my feet are just
here and I'm going to
turn just
turning I'm trying to avoid this
trying to avoid
this
turn is going this way this
way here's the timing can't do it or I
can't do it here I didn't turn and
late can't do it early it's behind
me
turns the hand stays in front of me the
entire
time stays in front
me never goes behind
me do not go above my head
okay that said the higher his hand the
better Advantage he has you can see his
posture I don't need all
this I have two things at my disposal in
this drill I can bend my
knees I don't want it up here
I bend my
knees second thing you do and your hand
is going out your head is going out the
Apex which is here in the elbow your
head goes into the back here right there
don't be at the hand part right here's
where you
go so I coming around right there where
I go you want to feel for
that third thing you can do
is just a slight head yield at the
end he's hitting in I
yield in the technique your stance
drops and your feet separate but here
we're simplifying it then we want to get
the hand in front of
us I am not suggesting you going like
this I didn't do
that okay TR keep your hi in front of
you all right so I'm in the
drill he's at the Y line or I'm going to
start to move it towards the
midline okay his hand is on my midline
and now as I'm manipulating it
it's going to stay on the on my midline
it stays right here the whole time I'm
turn
it whole
time go
back I go to the
midline this hand stays right there as I
turn stay there stay there stay there
stay there stay
there stay
there the beginner mistake is they can't
see how a circle can generate
verticality so there you go
okay long line they have to go up now
just try it trust
it oh God no stop going to work keep
trying
it here we are tight
D
different now you're going to do that
right here I put it back on the Y Line
with my shoulder now I TR to try to lift
it don't hurt my shoulder but if he
resists I can't lift
it anywhere in this action stay there
anywhere in this action he is stronger
than me I can't get it up from here
can't get it up so we'll get to here go
go I can't get it up you understand it
just looks like
it
go anywhere he wants to pull
it go I can't pull it you can't pull it
can't stop that and it gets worse as I
go higher pulls it I cannot stop
it you go
here and I'm not lifting it
you
see it's just class to Jitsu move
you don't move him I go under his arm
now his arm goes over my head okay try
it again